also habe ich gemacht heute ich hab sie
getroffen haben uns auf einen kaffee
getroffen so wie sie das vorgeschlagen
hatte in ihrem brief sie kam direkt an
habe ich mir gedacht so krass es ist zu
wild leute das ist wirklich einfach zu
bild ich hab da was sagst du dazu sehe
ich nämlich genauso leute es ist
tatsächlich passiert gehabt zum titel
gesehen leute es ist so weit gekommen
ich habe tatsächlich die personen die
vor etwas über einer woche vor genau
acht tagen ein brief an meine tür
geheftet hat mit der aufschrift an den
schönen unbekannten diese person habe
ich tatsächlich getroffen hatte ich habe
es noch kaum glauben und ich werde euch
im heutigen video mal erzählen wie diese
ganze sache ablief und euch mal komplett
berichten wie das tatsächlich vorgeht
wenn so was einem im leben passiert was
in dem film eigentlich passiert dass
eine fremde person irgendwie zettel an
der tür hängt man dann treffen wenn man
die wirklich treffen also darum geht zum
heutigen video leute selber versteht
punkte gemacht haben wir sie gefragt
leute wenn ihr so ein video sehen will
und was will durch drin wünschen dir mir
gesagt was sich wünschen würden
vielleicht versuchen das heute alles
betreiben zunehmen werde ich versuchen
euch von vorne bis hinten zu erzählen
wie es weiterging ab dem ende des
letzten videos dazu videos ja da geendet
dass ich ihr gesagt habe dass wir
geschrieben habe da hat glaube ich
aufgehört von vor vier tagen und jetzt
geht es quasi genau da weiter leute
falls ihr das sollte noch nicht kennt
ganz kurz zusammenfasst für euch am
abend des 30
aprils der hatte ich gerade 420 stunden
hund adoptieren video gedreht hinein
brief an meiner haustür unten im haus wo
20 andere leute wohnen an den schönen
unbekannten mit dem shanty oder sogar
die aufschrift hat sich hätten sogar
noch mal hier ich zeige euch dennoch
macht ja vielleicht eine sache vorneweg
noch mal wenn man so was auf youtube
sieht bei anderen youtube ist man
vielleicht mal geneigt zu denken
wer weiß auf das fake ist leute ich
erwarte wirklich mein linkes anliegen
wenn diese geschichte belogen ist könnt
ihr vorbeikommen und einfach mein linkes
ohr abschneidet mitnimmt ist kein
problem für mich denn diese geschichte
ist zu 1000% war und so passiert wie ich
erzähle
so leute dann formal in der story also
genau die geschichte geht weiter dass
ich sie angeschrieben hatte und dann
erst mal relativ lange
nichts zurück kam weil ich ja selbst
schon relativ lange pause hatte also sie
hat am 30 april diesen zettel an meiner
haustür gehängt mit diesem brief und
ihre handynummer aufgeschrieben von ich
wusste halt erst wirklich überhaupt
nicht was ich damit mache ich dachte
erst würde das so ein ding so jo machst
du so in story von post ist auf ihn
zugegangen
dann hat sich die sache erledigt oder
machst du nix mit nein was ich sagen
wollte ist leute ich hab mir glaube ich
erst am zweiten oder dritten meydan
zurückgeschrieben 30 april ihr zetteln
so auf der timeline dritter mai dann so
meine antwort habe ich zurückgeschrieben
so hajo vielen dank für den zettel ich
werde euch hier nochmal den zettel
einfälle die den zettel im letzten video
nicht gesehen haben und sie hat ihn auf
dem zettel wird auch vorgeschlagen dass
wir mal einen kaffee trinken gehen und
dann hat diese beschrieben hey danke für
den zettel
ja ich war tatsächlich mega überrascht
so was an meiner tür zu finden aber wir
können gerne mal einen kaffee trinken
gehen so habe ich nichts dagegen
liebe grüße der mit dem shanty so das
ist alleine so naja ok muss los oder gas
wohlgemerkt leute ja ich bin nicht blind
in die sache rein gestellt hat dass nach
dem ich erst mal ihre handynummer auch
bei whatsapp eingegeben habe und erst
mal gecheckt haben
wer steckt hinter diesem profil
zumindest anhalt das profil willst nicht
dass da irgendwie so nicht dass es die
nummer von irgendeinem mir das egal ob
männlich oder weiblich und dem ich dann
irgendwie dort oder sowas nein das war
eine reale person und es war eine sehr
sehr hübsches mädchen muss man sagen
tatsächlich ein hübsches mädchen
ich muss ein echter noch ein paar worte
an sie richten also falls so dass
irgendwann hier siehst liebe ich mag es
nicht einnahmen weil so mache ich
natürlich nicht sehr klar ist
wahrscheinlich bist du jetzt würde ich
jetzt zusehen dass ich tatsächlich
youtuber binden so und das ich habe
nicht gelogen weil das was ich mache
aber dass ich darüber jetzt auch videos
machen so ich hoffe dass es cool finde
ich wenn ich kann es mir einfach
schreiben und dann keine ahnung ja leute
wir haben dann wie es ganz normal ist
einfach so ein bisschen hin und her
geschrieben so bisschen abgecheckt kann
man sich ein bisschen unterhalten und
sympathisch man konnte sich unterhalten
also habe ich dann gedacht dass wir
jetzt einfach mal damit es ist
eigentlich ein zu krasser moment ist es
zu einmalig und zu außergewöhnlich dass
du da nicht hinterher geht nicht heißt
dass das profilbild auf rezept war so
nett aus auf jeden fall so ist ein
bisschen hübsches mädchen wie gesagt und
das ist mir kommen egal probiert es
einfach mal aus
wer weiß ob so etwas noch mal passiert
in einem leben oder ganze im nachhinein
halt dann nur sagen ja ich hatte mal so
ist an der tür aber ich habe die person
nicht getroffen also mist gemacht heute
ich hab sie getroffen haben uns auf
einen kaffee getroffen so wie sie das
vorgeschlagen hatte in ihrem brief und
ja dort jetzt endlich mal von dem date
was wir dann tatsächlich hatten vorne
weg ich werde jetzt nicht irgendwelche
privaten informationen über sie also wer
sie als person ist was sie macht und so
weiterhin dieses video rein tragen weil
das wirklich nicht hier rein gehört hier
ist quasi nur ich dokumentiere hier nur
meine geschichte also mein leben letzten
endes auf diesem youtube kanal und das
heißt ich gebe euch informationen soweit
das für die geschichte hier nötig ist
aber eben auch mit respekt erwarte also
als er uns dann getroffen und das ganze
ging so loswerden ein treffen vereinbart
direkt vor meiner haustür sagt dann
treffen uns tag bei mir so weil also
immer noch darüber geschrieben positive
und uns so ungewohnt relativ in der nähe
deswegen ist ja auch bei mir
vorbeigelaufen mit ihrem hund und ihre
runde mit dem hund wird irgendwie so an
meiner haustür vorbei deswegen kamen sie
auch bei mir vorbei sein und ja da
musste ihr volk nicht mehr sagen wo ich
wohne da haben uns ja schon mal ein haus
getroffen und johanna fabriken zum
kaffeetrinken sie kam direkt an habe ich
mir gedacht so krass artillerie schon
zwei kaffee in der hand fand ich krass
erstmal erste mal dass die wir schon so
voraus geplant hat rückwirkend falls es
aber mega suite und so zuvorkommend und
sowas einfach so kleine aufmerksamkeiten
leute die wirklich funktionieren fand
ich megane also im rückblick ich war
erstmal mit der situation komplett
überfordert natürlich leute ist doch
klar oder was hättet ihr mal was hättet
ihr mal wieder gewarnt natürlich mal
überfordert so und ja dümmste was wir
eigentlich aktuell machen kann
gf mal so zu ihr hin und machen sie so
bekommen wird alle schutzmaßnahmen die
aktuell so gelten so vergessen aber war
einfach die aufregung denn direkt
nachdem ich im amt hat sie war auch so
müssen wir auf distanz zum abend kann
ich dann so steht ja da war ja was
aktuell so sorry aber jetzt gerade
vorbei da haben wir dann spazieren
gemacht und ich muss sagen heute es ist
wirklich ihr könnt euch das bestimmt
vorstellen oder es ist schon eine etwas
würde weil ungewöhnliche erfahrung wenn
man so einen zettel an seiner haustür
hat dann einfach nur über whatsapp
profilbild die person
sieht und dann auf einmal steht die
person vor einem und man redet mit der
macht ein spaziergang
diejenigen von euch die vielleicht ein
bisschen älter sind und schon paar mal
auf dates waren wissen auch wie das
abläuft wenn man mal so eine fremde
person die man vorher noch nicht gekannt
hat zum beispiel über t know what ever
oder sonstwie online dann tatsächlich
trifft so das ist meistens immer
probiert am anfang
das ist so leute kann ich euch sagen es
ist meistens wirklich wer also das war
die begrüßung und dann sind wir
gestartet heute ja wie gesagt es ist
einfach so am anfang letztes bisschen
gehört wir haben dann aber einfach so
einfach so das gespräch am laufen
gehalten haben so bisschen getraut was
wir so machen was was nicht so mache was
sie so macht habe so paar andere sachen
über mich erzählt und ja sie hat paar
sachen über sich erzählt ja leute und
dann sind wir in den park denn hier ganz
in der nähe ist und haben dann wie
gesagt anderthalb bis zwei stunden lange
so unsere runden gedreht haben über
alles mögliche geredet genau und das war
jetzt ein ende so der der inhalten
unseres aids einfach längerer
spaziergang und jah-ren effekt ich habe
am ende dann noch irgendwie hunger
gehabt und dann habe ich noch irgendwie
bei einem laden in der nähe telefonisch
bestellt und sie wir dann auch zusammen
hingelaufen haben wir gewartet weiter
getaucht war alles möglich weil ich mein
essen dann hatte dann haben wir uns
quasi verabschiedet dass man so als
rahmen informationen leute mir das ganz
ohne so eine sache eingefallen
das erinnert mich und wie gerade so
krass hier an bachelor was ich gerade
mache das einfach so öffentlich
zugänglich ist wieso zwei menschen sich
kennenlernen das gibt mir ganz kassel
bachelor vibes naja ok gut ist es
einfach mal ein experiment um auf ein
stück von mir einzugehen denn meine
kumpels mehr gegeben haben sie meinten
ich heute darüber reden ob das date
kretschmer und ja also man muss also
nicht ja es war gewinnt man muss sagen
es war einfach wie es so normal ist wenn
man einfach menschen trifft mit dem man
vorher noch nicht lange kontakt hat
immer nicht länger kennt auch nicht aus
dem freundeskreis kennt und den dann zum
ersten mal live zu den personen sieht
dann ist das meistens natürlich ein
bisschen kritisch so ist ja klar so
triste komplett fremde person von der
duh bisher nur so ein whatsapp
profilbild kennst und dann steht die
vorder und dann müsst ihr miteinander
zeit verbringen so das ist jeder der
schon mal so online dating oder sowas in
der art gemacht hat weiß dass das ist
erstmal aber ansonsten ganz gut
gehandelt also der der quint faktor war
auf jeden fall recht gering von diesem
date würde ich sagen also ich hatte ich
hatte sonst immer
auf jeden fall ich hatte auf jeden fall
schon dates da habe ich die person
begrüßt und wusste so nach zehn sekunden
nein das wird auf gar keinen fall was
und du machst das jetzt einfach nur
brings das zu ende einfach aus
höflichkeit verbringen es jetzt
irgendwie anderthalb stunden zeit mit
der person weil wenn ich jetzt irgendwie
ein eiskalter menschen würde ich
vielleicht sofort nach zehn minuten
abbrechen oder sowas aber bin ich nicht
so noch ein stichpunkte meine jungs mit
gegeben haben ist es war es so wie es
mir vorgestellt habe schwierige frage
eigentlich weil ich habe mir nicht ganz
konkret das volk oder wartet vielleicht
doch vielleicht habe ich mir so bisschen
so über krass romantisch vorgestellt
dass das so ganz anders wird als alles
andere was man so davor in diese
richtung unternommen also dating mäßig
oder whatever weil ja die art und weise
wie man sich kennenlernt ganz anders ist
ebenso mittelalters teil sondern sie
möchte mit so einem zettel an der tür
aber ich muss sagen das war eigentlich
eine relativ normale erfahrung also es
war nicht geisteskrank anders in dem
fall war es glaube ich einfach die art
und weise wie man sich kennenlernt die
anders war und der rest läuft dann
einfach trotzdem relativ normal ab ich
hätte mir bei dem data vielfach
vorgestellt dass es ein bisschen wird
wird das war mir klar weil es halt
einfach so die story ist einfach so
immer mit dabei wie geht somit dritte
person die somit geht die kennenlern
story klar ist es ein bisschen gehört
also aber es okay also unterm strich
muss man sagen sollte sich auf jeden
fall eine sehr sympathische person denn
der letzte stichpunkte meine jungs
wirklich jemand ist nochmal treffen
fragezeichen das ist eine sache die ich
eigentlich stand jetzt noch nicht so
ganz genau beantworten also nochmal
treffen kann ich wahrscheinlich schon
beantworten ich denke wahrscheinlich
schon ja wohl die ganze sache dann
hingeht aber genauso also ich bin nach
wie vor bisschen weder dauert wissen
geflasht bisschen auch gehabt von diesem
ding so und davon dass das jetzt hier
auf youtube stattfindet schreiben wir
wieder eure meinung zu der ganzen sache
und in die kommentare reichen sollte
eine sache wo ich noch sagen und zwar
das sagen mir was sie gesehen habe das
ist nicht sie weil ich natürlich kein
bild mit ihr gemacht habe beim ersten
date das ist eine andere person aus
meinem leben nichts zensiert habe hier
gibt's nicht völlig vorgeschlagen das
video hier oben könnt ihr meine knarre
berlin ist kostenlos und will mich sehr
freuen wenn der ausbleibt stabil bleibt
beim mittelalterlichen kennenlernen
weisen